5 gracias para ti a esta hora desde el
consejo nacional electoral a presidente
del órgano comicial está ofreciendo un
discurso específicamente para dar la
inauguración de lo que será la jornada
electoral el día de hoy de segunda
vuelta donde los ecuatorianos 13
millones de cotidiano serán habilitados
para ejercer el derecho al voto algunas
puntualidades que ha dicho en este
momento cuando se desarrolla el discurso
habla sobre que se ha reforzado el
sistema para evitar apagones
informáticos y se ofrece también un
aplicativo móvil cn app para ofrecer así
los resultados no habrá conteo rápido
para ofrecer las tendencias oficiales
definitivas de igual forma también habla
de que los primeros resultados se
conocerán a partir de las 19 horas a las
primeras tendencias oficiales no serán
así los resultados definitivos y de
igual forma indica que las encuestas
empresas encuestadoras empezarán a
ofrecer los resultados a partir de 17
horas no serán estos resultados
definitivos pero también ha hecho una
puntualidad es ha advertido a los
candidatos andrés grados
guillermo lasso de si hay un margen
estrecho el día de hoy los resultados
inclusive podrían conocerse el día de
mañana
gustavo y para los resultados finales
cuando los podríamos conocer
oficialmente que ha dicho el consejo
nacional electoral al respecto
[Música]
el consejo nacional electoral ha emitido
una información que hay que tomar en
cuenta específicamente la presidenta del
órgano comicial ha enviado unos
comunicados a los comandos de campañas
de andrés araujo guillermo lazos y ella
expresa que habrá 508 centros de
votación de difícil acceso en los que
los resultados probablemente no se
conozcan el día de hoy eso quiere decir
que el margen entre ambos candidatos
sería muy estrecho podría conocerse los
resultados a partir del día de mañana
inclusive estamos hablando de 64 mil
votos que en este caso si el más ritmo
derecho será realmente importante
recibir estos últimos resultados